but so let me ask you so where were you
born that where did you grow up like
high school and all that kind of stuff
Sacramento yeah it's what a beautiful
they have a Jamba Juice there yeah I
went to that one I remember I mean III
didn't get robbed I didn't get robbed
yeah I also sucked on a seven-year old
wound titty boy the grandma with the
kids toys titty no you gotta explain
this one
what no after a show you know a lady an
old lady goes young man young man how
old are you I must have been 30 wait
where where in Sacramento the punch line
the punch line yeah young man what a
wonderful show young man and she shook
my hand you know I mean like political
style yeah so shook it I go thank you
you know and but there was a piece of
paper in the hand oh right so looked at
it and I went to Kevin Christie who was
actually opening for me in Denver this
weekend and kept I go I got this lady
because you should call it you should
call it yeah and I go oh yeah so that
night I try to get her to come to my you
mean hotel room and with yeah and then
the next day she goes let me pick you up
and it was a Bronco oh she's a badass
grandma man was it white he was a white
Jay Simpson style yeah and then she um
we had dinner and then at dinner I go
she pay no I think I did and then she
goes you want to see my titties and I go
now at dinner I'm not kidding you at
dinner she goes look and she hadn't done
she was like one of those like hip-hip
hot yeah you know I mean like ladies
like in its in her 20s I would never
even get be able to get her Yeah right
it's only at 60 I could get her
[Laughter]
so then we she goes she was driving me
around Sacramento to show me like the
landmarks yeah I mean like this is hey
you know this is where they make the
landmark this is where they make you
know lamp fixtures almond factor all the
factory there yeah that's something to
be proud of
yeah so then and then just sucked on her
titties and butt was weird because I we
had parked on the side of the street and
she had her grandkids toys all over the
all over the Broncos I had an armored
adjusting and it was a child oh really
yeah yeah so then you grew up in sac I
want to hear that story wait so how do I
look it was just the second on the
titties word yeah I would have had
sexual intercourse with her but I had to
do two shows so that's ever stopped a
man before no it was like like my show
was at seven and I was sucking all
titties at 6:30
oh it was a time real time crunch yes I
was like doing it quick because like I
wanted to get it all in no rain check
why didn't I call I think I called her
that night and then and then she brought
the sunday show she brought her youngest
son yeah she has a young son that's like
16 or 17 oh that's to this to the before
the show
and then we took photos and he was a
huge MADtv fan so then after that I was
like this is becoming kind of weird too
familiar you're family now
yeah I don't want to be I didn't also I
don't think I wanted him to be my um
yeah means son yep son yeah things you
know went further hello we're gonna take
a quick break to share an amazing
sponsor with
[Music]
shipstation man when you're selling
online getting your orders can